but we're going to shift gears a little
bit um and bring the tone down over the
last several days veteran activists have
gathered outside the u.s capitol to
protest what they call massive
legislative injustice against millions
of americans the pact act lost a
procedural vote last week after several
senate republicans suddenly changed
sides the bill would expand health care
and disability benefits to veterans who
were exposed to toxic burn pits in iraq
and afghanistan president biden says he
will sign the bill if it is approved
former daily show host jon stewart has
joined the demonstrations to support
senate passage of the pac act stewart is
one of the bill's most vocal supporters
and we are thankful that he is joining
us right now jon stewart how are you
doing this morning
good morning we're we're all we're a
little tired we're a little hoarse a
little worse for where but uh
determined
determined that's right now you've spent
a lot of time with these veterans who
are suffering and you know their
personal stories
what do people need to know about this
that they might not know
they're real people they're not they're
not heroes that we honor at halftime at
the super bowl and with lapel pins their
mothers and fathers and brothers and
sisters and aunts and uncles
and they are struggling and they served
this country and then the country
unfortunately turned their back on them
when they needed care after coming back
we always have trillions for war
but when it comes to the consequences of
those wars
suddenly everybody's digging through the
couch cushion so uh this has to change
just as a matter of principle and this
act
goes a long way towards making this
right i mean this act even helps vietnam
veterans that's how behind the curve we
are
in terms of caring for those who who
fought for the country
you know john it's vlad help our
audience understand this bill initially
passed with overwhelming bipartisan
support
back in june but you've gotten into a
tit for tat with several republican
senators ted cruz pat toomey uh who
voted against it this second time around
they're citing a number of reasons break
down what they're saying and what your
message is to them
so it's it's it's kind of complex as
everything is down here because you know
washington dc is like willy wonka
chocolate factory without any chocolate
or candy it's just all these bizarre
rooms that bring no joy to anybody uh
the bill passed uh the house and it went
to the senate they reformed a couple of
things that needed some looking at some
things that would help the va implement
the bill in a more practical way that
wouldn't cause uh any backlogs that
wouldn't cause difficulties with the new
influx of patients and the
specialization of the kind of treatment
they need right so that got done in may
they posted it on congress.gov
that bill which passed out of the
veterans affairs committee in the senate
by unanimous
all republicans all democrats went to
the floor of the senate june 16th it
passed 84 to 14.
so it was ready to go to the president
the house flagged a technical issue in
the bill it's called a blue slip
it had to do with
tax benefits if uh rural providers were
given money by the va to give veterans
who don't have access to the larger
facilities the same type of specialized
care that's all that changed nothing was
added to the bill it's the exact same
bill you can go on congress.gov you can
put them side to side it's the exact
same bill
one sentence removed about taxation for
rural providers
that bill went back oh and by the way it
gained 90 more votes in the house
republicans 90 more republicans then
signed on in the house goes back to the
senate you think it's a rubber stamp
vote
everybody gathers to celebrate
25 republicans in the senate switched
their vote from yes to no when nothing
had changed
so john when you hear when you hear that
um but you you also i'm sure i've heard
uh senator pat toomey talking about
costs and being concerned about uh
limits entitlements and and having
something set up in a way where congress
would have to continue to vote on this
to give those uh benefits to veterans uh
who deserve it
what is what do you think this is really
about and where do we go from here what
are you prepared to do if this doesn't
pass
well i mean we've got veterans sleeping
outside the capitol waiting for this to
go look i'm calling on majority leader
schumer to put this bill on the floor
today
pat toomey said he just wanted his
amendment voted on well they've offered
him that vote
it's there for him it's been offered i
think along with another amendment but
down here man negotiating is you watch
this thing go down we'll give you two
amendments and a side agreement and a
closure to be named later and they're in
all these rooms and they're making all
these things meanwhile the real people
who are suffering the effects of this
are sleeping outside the capitol and so
what i said is put it on the floor today
they're leaving for summer break
they're they're not going to be here
they don't work on mondays i said put it
on the floor on monday well they're not
here
put it on the floor tuesday well lunch
is at 12 and they said it was gonna rain
and you know three members are made of
sugar and so they can't do that
and and then what i said it's like hey
man if this is a budgetary issue don't
you have oversight well we do have that
so what are we waiting for
can't you guys
just say you'll have oversight later oh
yeah no we could do that everything down
here is impossible and of course they
could do it it's bizarre
it is bizarre indeed um john i know
you're here to
speak for the veterans and their
families and what they're going through
but if you would indulge me i would like
to ask you a personal question because i
see you as a selfless man someone is
using their voice for the voiceless um
why why are you you don't have to you
don't have why
i feel indebted
and i feel i mean these are people i
i've been in this community for about 20
years now
whether it be
uso shows or or the warrior games which
is an adaptive rehabilitative like
olympic type event uh achilles heel
freedom team i've gotten to know this
community very well i've gotten to know
their stories very well i've gotten to
know the undue burden that this country
places on military families it's a very
small percentage of the country we ask
them to sacrifice a great deal their
housing is often in shambles we've got
military veterans active duty on food
stamps within 830 billion dollar defense
budget
unconscionable
and i look at it as
as a bellwether
these are the people that we purport to
uphold as the best of us
and we can't even do right by them
so what chance do the rest of us have
for any kind of equity for any kind of
of fairness if they can't get health
care if they go bankrupt
from their cancers that were caused by
their service
what the hell are the rest of us
supposed to do
john
thank you so much for joining us and
thank you for your passion in your fight
right now thank you